i feel like by talking about things it
normalizes that shame and it brings it
right here to the point where you can be
like okay this is what we're dealing
with
and when you can do that you feel
a freedom that is hard to even explain
i mean you feel like you can breathe
deeper and you can wake up different
in in the morning and um and that's what
i want to help
other survivors feel your first album
in three years you took your time with
this one you poured
everything into it
how does it feel that the album is
finally here
i am so excited i'm so proud of this
music i've been working really hard on
it over the past
um gosh three years i guess um to finish
it and i just cannot wait to release it
to the world and
let people hear these songs and
hopefully the people who need to hear
them
yeah and can do that but i'm i'm just so
excited
what was your mindset going into this
album versus
your first one you know over the past
three years
i've i've i've gone through a lot a lot
has happened in
my life and it was about halfway through
writing this record
when i realized you know i'm writing
these songs in order of how i'm
processing this time of my life right
now you know from
from heartbreak as a whole in my life in
general
uh um from turning 30 from having a
health scare i'm
i'm sort of processing all of these
things and how cool would it be
to write a concept album in
order of how i'm going through this
process
i'm a huge nerd about a lot of things in
life but
but i love reading up about you know
personal development and
all things brene brown and all those
things and um
i was like how cool would it be to write
a record around the seven stages of
grief
where the seven stages of grief are just
basically one way of articulating the
process
of as as human beings the way we
we feel things and the way we process
them and so
um i did just that i wrote an album
and track one starts in stage one of
shock and then it goes through shock
denial anger bargaining all the way down
to stage seven the last stage of
acceptance of being able to look in the
mirror
and accept yourself for everything that
you are knowing that everything that's
happened to you in your life has
happened for a reason
and and you know makes you into the
beautiful messy puzzle pieces that we
show up as every day
i feel like you're gonna help so many
people with
this album does that make you emotional
at all
thank you for saying that um no that's
exactly what i want to do
i i feel that music has the power to
heal
and it's that universal language to
bring us all together and and to connect
us
and um and so i really do hope these
songs can be support or empathy if
people are looking for that
or i really hope it inspires them to
sort of start their own
transformational journey to finding that
deeper level
of themselves because it's always within
us and and we're constantly transforming
and evolving as
as we go through life you know and as
things happen and
even through this global pandemic i mean
we're having to
ask a lot of questions and and you know
work on a lot of areas in our lives and
i know talking to a lot of my friends i
mean the past few months have been
have been big periods of transformation
where you're
where you're wondering okay how am i
doing my job how could i do my job more
efficiently
you know what are the small group of
friends that i really want to connect
with
or am i putting enough time into my
family like am i prioritizing the right
things in my life and so um
yes i really hope this album has has
legs and arms that um can inspire and
help a lot of people
were you opened up about your experience
as a sexual violence survivor
[Music]
mirror used to look so
innocent but that was all gone yesterday
what has the response been like for you
after sharing such a personal experience
like that
i had never talked about my story as a
little girl because i never wanted it to
be
about a publicity sense but i went to um
this place called youth for tomorrow
three years ago they're an organization
in the states that deal with kids who
have
gotten into the wrong situations or
youth specifically
12 to 18 who have been victims of sex
trafficking and rape
and i went there to help them launch
their music program three years ago and
i ended up sitting down at a conference
table with 12 other little girls
and i told them my story and i heard
their story and
they're things that are just so horrific
and so
i left that campus that day and was like
all right if i don't share my story
right now
then i'm holding back the opportunity to
help other little girls like that
or little boys like that or grown adults
because i feel like
it truly this happens far more in our
communities and our cities and our
towns more than we want to admit and um
and i just feel like the the
only way to
to to heal to help people heal is by
using our voices
and by by standing up and and saying
what we believe in
and you know if i would have had
somebody to hold little 13 year old
lindsay's hand
or 21 year old lindsay's hand and tell
her it was gonna be okay i feel like i
would have healed so much
faster so i decided to write a song
about it it's called make you
the cracks will heal which you'll always
feel the break
and that's what's gonna make you
i wrote it with brandy clark on this
album and um and i was able to launch my
own foundation as well
it's called the makey movement and the
foundation focuses on disenfranchised
youth specifically survivors
of sexual violence and domestic abuse
and i
truly just want other survivors to know
that they are not alone
and we can lean on each other just as my
female artist friends we can lean on
each other as survivors and
and know that that we're working through
this together you know it's one thing to
put something so personal into your art
to help other people heal too but then
to also release this song on global
forgiveness day i feel like
is so significant for so many reasons
how long did it take you and when did
you get to that point where you
were ready to forgive
you know i um from the first occurrence
when i was 13 i didn't tell my parents
for seven years
and um and those seven years were
were pretty heavy to be honest um
but i i forgave him
before i even told my parents and i
think that's maybe why i told my parents
as i finally got to that that place of
forgiveness
um you know obviously as a survivor it's
different in absolutely every case
and i think the the main
level of forgiveness is forgiveness of
yourself it is one thing to forgive
people in our lives who you know in in
various circumstances may have
have done things right or wrong but to
forgive ourselves
is truly where i feel the deepest level
of healing
lies because um we just carry so much
shame
and guilt and blame for things that
aren't our fault
or even are our fault but we we can't
carry that with us for the rest of our
lives because that's such a heavy weight
to carry
and so i feel like by talking about
things
it normalizes that shame and it brings
it
right here to the point where you can be
like okay this is what we're dealing
with
and when you can do that you feel
a freedom that is hard to even explain
i mean you feel like you can greek
deeper and you can wake up different
in in the morning and um and that's what
i want
to help other survivors feel this album
is the
is the seven stages of grief where are
you where are you at now how is your
heart now
my heart is good the the last song on
the record is ready to love
and i fully feel that i fully feel in
the place of acceptance and i feel that
acceptance is not
only being able to accept our past but
being able to open yourself up to new
things
and i truly feel open my heart is
um in the place where i'm just ready to
to
release this music and i'm also ready to
accept
love in ways that i i haven't been you
know
before what kind of energy do we want to
attract what kind of
love are we ready for
oh my gosh this is a great question we
want to attract
just creative and and connected
and open and
and exciting love i just want all of it